c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
aura pas d'impact à baba
voici bientôt quatre longues semaines
que les gens normaux j'entends les gens
issus de la norme avec deux bras et deux
jambes pour signifier qu'ils existent
subiste à longueur d'antenne les
dégradant de contorsions manchote des
hordes ans qu'elle sonnait sudoripares
qui se dispute sur gazon l'honneur
minuscule d'être les champions de la
balle au pied
voilà bien la différence entre le singe
et le footballeur le premier a trop
demain ou pas assez de pied pour
s'abaisser à jouer au football
le football quel sport est plus laid
plus balourd et moins gracieux que le
football quelle harmonie quelle élégance
les stades de base pourrait-il bien
découvrir dans les 30 in man pato de 22
ans handicapée velud qui poussent des
balles comme on pousse un étron en
amenant des râles vulgaire de buzz et un
qu'elle bâtards en rut de quel corniaud
branlée oserait manifester publiquement
sa libido en s'enlaçant frénétiquement
comme ils le font par paquet de 8 à
grands coups de patte grâce est mouillé
en nuland et gutturale ite simiesque a
choqué à rocker du sinn
quelle brute glacé quel monstre
décérébrés de quel ordre noir aux rires
sur des cadavres comme nous le vîmes
sans vérité certains soirs du sl ou vos
idoles calamiteux goa liste extatique
ont exulté de joie folle au milieu de 40
morts piétinés tout ça parce que la
balle était dans les bois
je vous ai footballeur vous ne m'avez
fait vibrer qu'une fois le jour où j'ai
appris que vous aviez attraper la
chiasse mexicaine en suisse ans
en suçant des frites aztèque
j'eusse aimé que les amis beaucoup
passent les pattes jusqu'à la fin du
tournoi mais dieu n'a pas voulu ça ne
m'a pas surpris de sa part il est des
vôtres
il est comme vous il est partout tout le
temps quoi qu'on fasse et ou qu on se
planque on ne peut y échapper
quand j'étais petit garçon je me suis
cru longtemps anormales parce que je
vous repousse est déjà je refusais
systématiquement de jouer au foot à
l'école ou dans la rue on me disait à la
vie à la vie ou bien tiens il est malade
tellement l'idée d'anormalité est
solidement solidaire de la non football
it et
je vous emmerde je n'ai jamais été
malade
quant à la féminité que vous subodh
auriez elle est toujours en moi et me
pousse au temps chaud à rechercher la
compagnie des femmes y compris celle des
vôtres que je ne rechigne pas à culbuter
quand vous vibrer au stade
je vous signale par parenthèse que
c'était ce que je viens de vous dire
c'est un papier qui m'a été commandé par
le journal du dimanche tu peux pas être
un journal d'imbéciles puisque c'est le
groupe hachette et
ils m'ont dit qu'ils pouvaient pas le
passé parce que c'était pas bien écrit
donc vous vous êtes suffisamment nul
pour comprendre dans l'oubli à vous et
ça passera dans libéré semaine voilà une
à part ça je suis très content car les
enfants m'écrivent
une auditrice de 9 ans qui a
malheureusement oublié de me communiquer
son adresse me dit non mais ça va pas la
tête de dire des choses pareilles sur le
bon dieu
crétins va imbéciles signé anne neuf ans
que raison and ça va pas la tête
je ne ferai plus je te le promets
n'empêche que c'est pas moi c'est le bon
dieu qui a commencé
demande à ta mère d expliquer le
comportement du bon dieu avec les petite
fille de 9 ans en ethiopie ou au liban
moi j'ai pas tout compris mais ça fait
rien je t'embrasse petit âne
d'alexandre l'aumônier dix ans
j'écoute les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire je comprends pas tout quand
j'entends rire les autres ça m'énerve
je me dis c'est pas juste
c'est normal avec 120 à 10 ans on a
l'esprit éveillé à d'autres altitude
cassel ou plafonne les vieux de 30 ans
et plus al'inverse quand vous vous jouez
à zorro nous ne comprenons pas tout par
exemple quand il y en a un qui dit pente
est mort on comprend pas pourquoi celui
qui vient d'être touchée se relève en
disant ça fait rien on dirait que j'en
suis un autre
parce que nous quand on joue à la guerre
on en n'est jamais un autre je crois que
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas l'intelligence
on comprend pas tout moi aussi ça
m'énerve ça lui alexandre
pour en finir avec ce douloureux
problème de l'incommunicabilité entre
les générations
permettez-moi une anecdote familiale un
crétin mutins j'en ai plein mais
samantha aussi un crétin mutins m'a
offert un gadget imbéciles c'était une
petite boîte en bois dont une face vitré
abrite d'un préservatif
sur le côté et un petit marteau pointue
et une mise en garde tout à fait
consternante encore d'urgence brisé la
vitre
j'en ris encore
maman c'est quoi le truc dans la boîte
demande une petite fille de 11 ans qui
n'est à ses proches à sa mère laquelle
mère ayant dépassé depuis quand même
longtemps le stade super branché pernoud
bonjour le petit grain
est ce qu'on peut appeler une maman
moderne un peu gêné tout de même elle a
fait huit ans chez les soeurs avant de
voir le loup
cette maman se lance dans un court
sommes maire de contraception élastique
que l'enfant suit d'une oreille
distraite sans le moindre ébahissement
c'est super commandes telles poliment
mais enfin bon papa et toi c'est pas
votre problème
comment ça vous voulait plus d'enfants
et alors et alors de toute façon quand
on veut plus d'enfants ont fait plus
l'amour
mais messi mais messi mais enfin
pourquoi maman comment pour pour le
plaisir ah ben alors là vous êtes
vraiment des cochons tous les deux
[Musique]
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter et font rien qu'à
baiser dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
fait que non non